Profª.Tamar Gendler: O que eu
gostaria que vocês fizessem
é responder à seguinte pergunta:
Você tem…?...
Oh, espere um segundo,
isto diz votação fechada.
Vamos ver o que eu posso fazer
para abrir a votação.
Você…?...
Não, não funcionou.
Oh, isto é a coisa mais
desesperadamente horrível
que já me aconteceu.
OK. Slide atual.
[risos]
Eu já passei por coisas horríveis
piores que esta, me desculpem.
Não quero menosprezar todas
as coisas horríveis
que já aconteceram comigo.
OK. Então, vamos tentar de novo.
Aspectos práticos, blá blá...
OK. Você já tem um clicker?
A votação está aberta.
OK. E vocês têm 10 segundos.
Podem ver esta pequena contagem.
8, 7, 6, 5, 4... 92 pessoas, muitos
de vocês têm clickers.
OK.
Vamos ver o que aprendemos.
Parece que 97% de vocês
já têm clickers.
[risos]
Na verdade, eu comecei com
este exercício
para fazer uma consideração sobre
a pesquisa psicológica.
[risos]
Nós cometemos um erro
clássico e perigoso,
um erro conhecido como
viés de amostragem.
Usamos uma medida que não nos
dá informações precisas
sobre o que queremos saber.
Queríamos saber
a porcentagem de pessoas na
sala com clickers.
E o que descobrimos, em vez
disso, foi que porcentagem
de pessoas com clickers
que tinha clickers.
[risos]
Eu não sei quem são vocês.
Este erro é extremamente perigoso
e poderia ter persistido.
Vamos supor que depois eu perguntasse
se você é da classe de
2014, 13, 12 ou 11
e descobrisse que 80% de vocês eram
calouros e alunos do 2º ano.
Então, novamente, eu teria herdado o
erro de viés de amostragem
que acabamos de observar.
Os calouros e alunos do 2º ano já
definiram os seus horários.
Consequentemente, eles estão certos
sobre as aulas que estão tendo.
Consequentemente, eles são mais
propensos a já terem clickers.
Portanto, ao fazer uma pesquisa
empírica psicológica
é preciso ter cuidado
extremo para que os meios,
na hora de escolher os
indivíduos dos experimentos,
sejam os que nos deem uma amostra fiel
do que nos interessa saber.
Um artigo foi publicado
recentemente na revista
Behavioral and Brain
Sciences com o título:
"As pessoas mais estranhas do mundo".
E "estranho" aqui significa ocidental,
educado, industrializado,
rico e democrático.
Ou seja, os estudantes
universitários norte-americanos.
Pessoas com acesso à votação
on-line pela internet.
O artigo argumentava
que uma grande quantidade de
pesquisa psicológica que pretende
fazer suposições gerais, que
pretende provar suposições gerais
sobre a natureza humana, é tendenciosa,
exatamente como a minha
pesquisa sobre os clickers.
Ela verifica uma pequena
amostra da população,
aqueles que estão prontamente
disponíveis para as pesquisas
nas universidades; por exemplo,
a turma de Introdução à Psicologia.
E baseia as suas conclusões
sobre a natureza humana
nessa amostra.
Ao longo do semestre,
temos de estar atentos à leitura
dos estudos psicológicos
que fazem afirmações sobre
a natureza humana,
ao fato de que é possível que
algumas das coisas ditas
que se aplicam aos seres
humanos em geral,
em vez disso,
se aplicam apenas às pessoas estranhas.
Ocidental, educado,
industrializado, rico e
democrático.
E, em certos casos, os dados
seriam muito diferentes
se observássemos outra população.
Esse também é o caso dos
textos clássicos que vimos.
O processo que Platão e
Aristóteles assumem para si
não parece experimental do mesmo jeito
que a psicologia experimental
parece experimental.
Mas eles enfocaram uma amostra de
pessoas ao seu redor e,
com base nessa experiência,
tiraram conclusões sobre a
natureza humana.
Portanto, um pequeno lembrete de
algo que eu disse na 1ª aula
que às vezes se perde...
Em alguns aspectos, esta é uma
aula sobre a filosofia
e a ciência da natureza humana.
Em outros, esta é uma aula
sobre a filosofia ocidental
e a ciência da natureza
humana ocidental.
E precisamos estar atentos a
isso quando for relevante.
Então, na aula de hoje,
eu quero voltar ao assunto
do último encontro:
a questão sobre a natureza
partida da alma humana.
Vocês devem lembrar que na última aula
fomos apresentados a uma ótima
analogia de Platão sobre razão,
espírito e apetite,
exemplificada por um cocheiro,
um cavalo calmo e um cavalo selvagem.
E também a uma série de
outras distinções.
Os cérebros esquerdo e direito,
que eu confundi um monte de
vezes, se bem me lembro.
Fomos apresentados à diferença
entre tronco cerebral
e parte superior do cérebro.
Fomos apresentados rapidamente à
ideia de Freud de superego,
ego e id.
Mas nós não começamos a trabalhar
na tradição do duplo processamento.
E a aula de hoje
nos leva até onde a última aula parou,
com uma outra maneira típica para
distinguir as partes da alma.
Deixa eu dizer que há um
excelente motivo para pensar
que a pesquisa apresentada hoje
não está sujeita à
objeção do "estranho".
Ou seja, existem fortes
demonstrações interculturais
de quase todos os resultados que
eu vou comentar hoje.
E também há bons motivos
evolucionários para pensar
que os 2 sistemas postulados pelos
teóricos dos sistemas duplos
fazem parte, na verdade, de
qualquer ser humano
por causa do processo evolutivo, a que
todos nós fomos submetidos.
Eu queria começar com uma foto
de Edward Thorndike,
não porque ele é importante,
mas sim porque ele é bonito.
Isto é do arquivo público da
biblioteca de Nova York.
Edward Thorndike foi um psicólogo do
final do século 19/início
do século 20 que realizou
muitos importantes trabalhos
associacionistas com animais.
Mas ele também fez uma pesquisa,
publicada num artigo em 1922,
que de certa forma pode ser vista
como o trabalho fundador
da tradição do raciocínio
que Jonathan Evans
descreveu no artigo lido
para a última aula.
Ele explica, no seu artigo de
1922, uma experiência
intitulada "O efeito de dados
alterados no raciocínio".
E o que ele está interessado em saber
é se os problemas
formalmente idênticos,
mas que diferem no modo como esse
material formal é apresentado,
são processados ??de forma diferente.
Por exemplo, ele pediu para as
pessoas o quadrado de x + y e
o quadrado de b1 + b2.
Como as pessoas acham a
primeira pergunta fácil,
elas veem a segunda
questão mais difícil.
Os índices de sucesso em
[x/y] rondaram os 90%.
Os índices de sucesso em [b1/b2]
foram consideravelmente mais baixos.
Ou ele perguntou: qual é o quadrado
de a2 x3 em contraposição
ao quadrado de r18r112 ?
E assim por diante.
Ao apresentar os problemas que
eram formalmente idênticos,
mas que diferiam na complexidade
dos caracteres utilizados
para representá-los,
produziu-se um decréscimo
enorme no desempenho.
Vamos saltar a um período nas
décadas de 1960, 70 e 80,
em que as pessoas começaram a
estudar o raciocínio silogístico
e surgiram inúmeras instâncias
especiais desse fenômeno.
Assim, no texto de Jonathan
Evans da última aula,
vocês foram apresentados a
exemplos como este.
Um silogismo que era
válido e crível...
ou seja, cujas propriedades
formais garantiam
que se as premissas fossem
verdadeiras, a conclusão era verdade
e, afinal, a conclusão era verdade.
E os argumentos que eram
válidos, mas não críveis...
argumentos onde a sua
estrutura garantia que,
se as premissas fossem verdadeiras,
a conclusão era verdade,
mas ela era falsa.
Por exemplo, é possível ponderar:
Nenhuma tragédia grega é comédia.
Algumas peças de teatro
gregas são comédias.
E seguir a partir daí
que algumas peças gregas não
são tragédias gregas.
Nenhuma tragédia grega é comédia,
algumas comédias gregas são peças,
por isso, algumas peças gregas não
são tragédias gregas...
e 90% das pessoas viram esse
argumento como válido.
Por outro lado, é possível
apresentar um argumento,
igualmente válido, mas com uma
conclusão não crível.
Como: Nenhum romance russo é curto.
Alguns romances de
Dostoiévski são curtos.
Portanto, alguns romances de
Dostoiévski não são romances russos.
Trata-se de um argumento válido.
É um argumento válido com
uma conclusão falsa,
porque uma das premissas é falsa.
Mas ao chegar a um
resultado implausível,
apenas 55% das pessoas foram
capazes de reconhecer
que a conclusão procede das premissas.
Observem, porém,
que esses 2 argumentos são
estruturalmente idênticos.
Ambos têm uma forma: nenhum A é um B,
alguns Cs são Bs,
portanto, alguns Cs não são As.
As propriedades formais sozinhas
não determinam a nossa
capacidade de julgar a validez.
E também é verdade
que as propriedades formais sozinhas
não determinam nossa capacidade
de julgar a invalidez.
Assim, enquanto os argumentos válidos
com conclusões plausíveis
são considerados válidos em
cerca de 90% das vezes,
acabamos de ver que os
argumentos válidos
com conclusões improváveis
são considerados válidos
consideravelmente com menos
frequência.
Um erro ao inverso surge no caso
dos argumentos inválidos.
Argumentos inválidos com
conclusões plausíveis
são considerados válidos.
Consideramos que a forma do argumento
garante a verdade da conclusão.
Ao passo que o que garante a
verdade da conclusão,
nesse caso, não é nada mais do
que os fatos sobre o mundo,
em vez dos fatos sobre a
estrutura do argumento.
À luz desta condição de Thorndik,
vários pesquisadores vieram com
paradigmas de pesquisa
que demonstram isso que
acabamos de falar.
A mais famosa, a tarefa de seleção
de Wason pede às pessoas
para determinar qual dos 4
cartões elas precisam virar
para checar a veracidade de
uma afirmação.
Por exemplo, eu posso
afirmar o seguinte:
"se tem um A num lado, tem
um 3 no outro".
E então eu apresento os 4 cartões
e pergunto qual delas
você tem de virar.
Obviamente, você tem de virar o A,
é algo que todo mundo reconhece.
Você precisa comprovar se
existe um 3 no outro lado.
Claro, você não precisa virar o D.
Você sabe que os cartões
têm uma letra num lado
e um número no outro.
Portanto, não há risco
de que exista um A no outro lado aqui.
Mas as pessoas têm uma
tendência a pensar
que é preciso virar o 3 em
vez de virar o 7.
Mas vejam bem.
Justo do outro lado do 7 havia um A
e a afirmação era falsa.
Os cartões que precisam ser
checados são o A e o 7.
As pessoas acham esta tarefa
relativamente difícil.
Pois aqui está uma tarefa
estruturalmente idêntica
que as pessoas acham fácil.
"Se uma pessoa está bebendo cerveja,
a pessoa deve ter mais de 21."
Eu vou mostrar 4 cartões.
O bebedor de cerveja, o de refrigerante,
a pessoa com mais de 21
anos e a de 17 anos.
E qualquer um de vocês
faria o papel de vigilante
e descobriria que o jovem de 17 anos
está bebendo uma cerveja.
E, assim, aprenderiam exatamente o que
foi difícil de ver no caso
anterior, que os cartões que
vocês precisam virar são
o 1º e o último, e não o 1º e o 3º.
Agora, surgiram todo tipo de
explicações hipotéticas
de por que achamos a 2ª tarefa
mais fácil do que a 1ª.
Talvez a mais famosa delas
seja uma hipótese
dos psicólogos evolucionistas
Leda Cosmides e John Tooby,
que argumentam que nós temos dentro
o que eles chamam de um módulo de
detecção de trapaças
e que somos extremamente sensíveis
aos casos que envolvem
violações de regras normativas.
Portanto, percebe-se que a 2ª
difere da 1ª de 2 maneiras.
A 2ª está socialmente integrada,
enquanto a 1ª é puramente abstrata.
E vamos descobrir,
à medida que avancemos com
as nossas leituras,
que a incorporação social desperta
processos de raciocínio que,
de outra forma, não estão presentes.
Nós aprendemos isso na semana
passada, com o estudo dos olhos
em que descobrimos que as pessoas
são mais pró-sociais,
mais dispostas a se
envolverem em comportamentos
moralmente normativos, quando são
apresentadas visualmente,
com os olhos – em parte porque
isso desperta e ativa
um tipo de entendimento social
que todos nós temos.
Assim, a 1ª diferença entre a
tarefa inferior e a superior
é que a inferior invoca
a sociabilidade,
enquanto a superior é
puramente abstrata.
E a 2ª diferença entre as 2, é claro,
que se trata de uma regra normativa.
É sobre como as coisas deveriam ser.
Ao passo que essa é uma
regra descritiva.
É sobre como as coisas são.
Assim, a lição que podemos tirar
da tarefa de seleção de Wason...
Para aqueles que estão
interessados ??nela,
foram realizadas milhares
de variações,
que são muito interessantes
para dizer exatamente
onde as pessoas são boas e
onde não numa tarefa.
A lição que podemos tirar é a
que tem sido enfatizada
ao longo desta aula e da anterior:
que temos formas de
processamento de informações
que não se limitam a acompanhar
as propriedades formais.
E algumas dessas formas de
processamento de informações
envolve trazer à tona, digamos,
o que Platão chamaria
de partes da alma
que não estavam atentas à situação.
Agora... há uma pergunta no fundo?
Estudante: Sim, desculpe.
Na última tarefa,
quais exatamente foram os
indivíduos selecionados?
Eu realmente não entendo o
delineamento experimental.
Profª.Tamar Gendler: Portanto, o
delineamento experimental
em ambos os casos foi o seguinte:
você recebe uma frase
e precisa verificar a verdade dela.
E vem a pergunta: "é verdade
que, se tem um A num lado,
tem um 3 no outro? É verdade
que, se uma pessoa
está bebendo cerveja, a pessoa
deve ter mais de 21 anos?"
E diante dos 4 itens à sua
frente, você é confrontado:
"quais você precisa virar para
verificar a afirmação?"
Portanto, para verificar a afirmação
"se tem um A num lado,
tem um 3 no outro"
é preciso virar o A e o 7,
e não o A e o 3.
E isso deve se tornar óbvio para
você se você observar este caso
em que, para determinar se a
pessoa estava bebendo cerveja
– a pessoa deve ter mais de 21 –,
você precisa virar a carta
do bebedor de cerveja
e a carta da pessoa que, em
realidade, tem menos de 21.
Então, isso esclarece?
[aceno do aluno]
Excelente.
OK.
Os modelos de duplo
processamento tentam dar
uma explicação geral para o
que está acontecendo
nos casos que acabei de descrever
e nos casos que estou
prestes a descrever.
Eles sugerem que temos 2 mecanismos
relativamente autônomos
para o processamento de informações,
que foram chamados de todos
os tipos de coisas,
mas o modo mais normativo de
descrevê-los é,
simplesmente, sistema 1 e sistema 2.
Assim, enquanto o sistema 1 é
evolutivamente primitivo
– ele faz uso de partes do cérebro
que entraram relativamente
cedo no nosso processo evolutivo –,
o sistema 2 é evolutivamente
recente e envolve a função
cortical superior.
O sistema 1 é inconsciente,
ou pré-consciente,
enquanto o sistema 2 é consciente.
O sistema 1 opera automaticamente,
enquanto o sistema 2 é
conscientemente controlado.
O sistema 1 é fácil, ele
acontece sem a nossa tentativa.
O sistema 2 é esforçado,
no sentido em que envolve um
gasto de energia cognitiva;
você tem de prestar atenção.
O sistema 1 é super rápido.
Ele processa informações quase
que instantaneamente.
O sistema 2 é lento,
relativamente falando;
as informações que obtemos a
partir do sistema 2
levam muito mais tempo: segundos,
em vez de milissegundos.
O sistema 1 é associativo; ele
reconhece os padrões no mundo.
O sistema 2 é baseado em regras; ele
pode aplicar os princípios.
O sistema 1 é, como às
vezes dizem, reflexivo;
acontece sem reflexão, que é
a base do sistema 2.
Portanto, a distinção
entre os 2 sistemas
é o resultado de várias décadas
de trabalho de muita gente.
Aqui está um gráfico a partir de um
trabalho de Jonathan Evans
em que ele enumera – e isso estará
disponível para vocês no site v2 –
alguns dos muitos pesquisadores
que trataram sobre o
sistema 1 e o sistema 2.
E quero recordar uma coisa
importante aqui,
que é um pouco enganador falar
de sistema 1 e sistema 2
como se fossem 2 coisas individuais.
O sistema 1 algumas vezes é chamado
de conjunto autônomo de subsistemas.
A ideia: existe o processamento visual
e o processamento auditivo,
e existe o processamento que nos dá
informações muito específicas
sobre coisas como rostos
ou o comprimento médio de linhas ou
que nos permite reconhecer
algo como presa ou predador.
Todos esses sistemas têm as
características do sistema 1.
Eles são rápidos, são inconscientes,
são evolutivamente primitivos,
vêm à tona sem reflexão.
Mas eles não são, cada um deles,
não são em conjunto um
sistema coerente.
Os modelos de duplo processamento
são uma forma de tentar
dar sentido a um conjunto de fenômenos,
alguns deles têm a ver com o
processamento do raciocínio e outros,
como aprendemos no adorável discurso
de Daniel Kahneman no prêmio Nobel,
que pedi para vocês assistirem,
ocorrem num domínio mais
geral do raciocínio.
E eu reproduzi aqui um
gráfico de Kahneman
que explica o que ele entende sobre a
relação entre o sistema 1 e o 2,
onde ele fala sobre as semelhanças
entre a percepção e a intuição,
de um lado, e o raciocínio, do outro.
Eu vou colocar este slide no
site para vocês.
Então, o que eu quero fazer na
próxima parte da aula
é seguir com a discussão de Evans,
que deixamos na última aula
para conectá-la com esta,
e falar um pouco sobre o
trabalho de Daniel Kahneman
e do seu colaborador, Amos Tversky.
Vocês vão ter agora a 2ª chance
de usar os seus clickers.
Vamos fazer outro teste
hoje e, se funcionar,
teremos uma série completa na terça.
OK, então este é o famoso
problema da "doença asiática"
de Kahneman e Tversky, e funciona assim:
Uma doença terrível atingiu 600
pessoas na sua cidade.
Sem tratamento, todas elas
estão condenadas.
Você é o prefeito e há 2 condutas
de tratamento disponíveis.
Se o seu sobrenome começa com
uma letra de A a L, você
tem de ler as informações que eu
vou fornecer no quadro verde.
Portanto, com a sua cabeça
virada para este lado,
você só vai ler o que ocorre no verde.
Se o seu sobrenome começa de M a Z,
você vai ler as
informações do quadro
azul.
Se tudo correr bem,
nós vamos usar essas
convenções de cor sempre
e o grupo de A a L terá os números
'1' e '2' para sim e não,
enquanto o grupo de M a Z terá os
números '3' e '4' para sim e não.
Portanto, se você é um
M-Z, olhe para o azul
e prepare os seus dedos
nas teclas 3 e 4;
se você é um A-L, olhe
para o quadro verde
e prepare os seus dedos no 1 e 2.
Eu perguntei ao Marvin Chun como
preparar slides como este
e esta foi a sua sugestão.
OK. Todos prontos?
Vou explicar o plano A e o B
e vocês têm de olhar para o quadro
de vocês, não para o outro.
OK? Então, leiam o plano A.
E agora, leiam o plano B.
OK. Peguem os seus clickers e,
se você é da equipe verde, use '1'
para indicar a escolha do plano A
e '2' para indicar a escolha do plano B.
Se você está na equipe azul, use '1'
para indicar a escolha do plano A
e '2' para indicar a escolha do plano B.
OK. Eu vou acionar o cronômetro.
Queremos de 64 a 66 zilhões e
zilhões e zilhões de respostas.
Vamos ver os números que saem.
OK. Aqui estão os números...
OK. Na equipe verde, 40% de
vocês escolheram o plano A.
Já na equipe azul, apenas 25%
escolheram o plano A.
Ah, quer saber? Isto não
é... Então... Nós...
O tamanho relevante da barra é
relevante, mas está dividido em 100.
Eu preciso aprender um pouco mais
sobre como usar os clickers.
Então deixa eu reagrupar e
retomar o meu raciocínio.
Como vocês podem ver, na equipe verde,
a preferência em relação ao plano A
excedeu a preferência
relativa pelo plano B.
Na outra pequena metade da classe...
o problema consiste em que 60% de
vocês estão em A a L
e apenas 40% estão em M a Z...
este é o problema.
OK.
Mas, neste grupo, se eu pudesse
fazer rapidamente 26 x 0,4
seríamos capazes de saber o
percentual absoluto.
Neste grupo, a preferência
relativa é pelo plano B,
em vez do plano A.
Observem, porém, que o plano A e o
plano B são idênticos.
Há 600 pessoas.
E no plano A, 200 pessoas vivem;
o que significa que 400 pessoas morrem.
E deste lado, há 600 pessoas;
se optamos pelo plano A,
400 pessoas morrem,
o que dá a certeza de que
200 pessoas vivem.
No entanto, os resultados
demonstrados são, na verdade,
tais como o conjunto
típico de resultados.
Normalmente, as pessoas que se
deparam com um problema
que envolve uma escolha entre a
certeza e a probabilidade
enquadrada nos termos dos resultados
positivos optam pelo certo,
em vez do plano arriscado.
Ao passo que as pessoas,
dita a mesma coisa,
onde é dada a ênfase na certeza de
que 400 pessoas vão morrer,
tendem a selecionar a
opção probabilística.
Observe novamente: o plano A e o B
são exatamente os mesmos.
Somente que um está
enquadrado em quem vai viver
e o outro em quem vai morrer.
E o resultado é quase uma
inversão completa
das preferências das pessoas.
E temos esse tipo de
efeitos de enquadramento
de maneira repetida.
Aqui está um estudo de um aluno
de Kahneman e Tversky,
Eldar Shafir, do início dos 1990.
Você vai a uma sorveteria
e está ávido por pedir 2
sabores de sorvete.
Um deles é bom e o outro é delicioso,
mas apresenta um alto
nível de colesterol.
E você descobre que só tem dinheiro
para comprar 1 dos sabores.
Então, se eu pergunto qual
você escolheria,
28% das pessoas escolheriam o
sorvete bom e 72% das pessoas
escolheriam o delicioso com
colesterol alto.
Mas se eu perguntar qual
deles você desistiria,
55% das pessoas desistiriam do bom
e 45% das pessoas desistiriam do sabor
delicioso com colesterol alto.
Então mesmo que, neste caso, 28%...
mesmo que seja exatamente a mesma
pergunta, qual você escolhe?
Se você escolher A, você desiste de B.
Se você escolher B, você desiste de A.
Estes números não correspondem.
Quando perguntado qual você
escolhe, o delicioso se agiganta
e você opta por ele,
negligenciando o colesterol
alto.
Quando perguntado qual
deles você desiste,
o colesterol alto fica ainda maior.
Esse fenômeno ocorre de forma regular.
Vamos supor que você esteja indo
para o cinema e, ao chegar,
você descobre que perdeu alguma
coisa na sua carteira.
O que você perdeu ou é
uma nota de US$ 10
ou um ingresso de cinema
no valor de US$ 10
comprado na noite anterior.
Você chega ao cinema, abre a sua
carteira para, no 1º caso,
retirar os US$ 10 e
comprar o ingresso ou,
no 2º caso, retirar a sua
entrada já comprada,
e descobre que você perdeu o item
que permite o seu acesso ao cinema.
No entanto, você tem outra nota
de US$ 10 na carteira
e a pergunta é: você
compra outro ingresso?
Para as pessoas que perderam uma
nota de US$ 10 no caminho,
90% dizem: "Eu perdi US$ 10, e daí?
Eu vou comprar um novo ingresso".
Para quem perdeu um ingresso de US$ 10,
exatamente o mesmo valor que
uma nota de US$ 10,
apenas 42% afirmaram que
gastaria os US$ 10
para comprar outra entrada.
Portanto, o enquadramento é um dos
exemplos de uma heurística,
ou viés, que Kahneman e Tversky
focam no seu trabalho.
Voltaremos a outros exemplos
mais adiante no semestre,
ao lermos a obra de Cass Sunstein.
O que eu quero salientar agora é
um exemplo particular,
que vai servir como seguimento
dentro da ideia de alief.
E esta é a diferença entre
frequência e probabilidade.
Vamos supor que você esteja tentando
conseguir 1 bola vermelha,
porque isso ajuda a ganhar um prêmio.
E você pode optar se deseja
tirar desta caixa aqui,
que tem 9 bolas brancas e 1 vermelha,
ou desta caixa aqui, que tem 8
bolas vermelhas e 92 brancas.
Nesta você tem 10% de chance,
aqui você tem 8% de chance.
Você vai tirar a bola com
os olhos vendados.
Uma imagem que eu não
recomendo pesquisar
no Google.
[risos]
Eu busquei "justiça com os
olhos vendados"...
Isso torna a coisa um pouco melhor.
Tudo bem.
Então você tem a sua escolha.
Você está tentando
conseguir a bola vermelha:
você escolhe esta caixa ou
você escolhe esta caixa?
Claro, racionalmente,
você tem mais chances aqui.
Mas as pessoas estão tentadas
nas duas direções.
Você tem 10% de chance aqui,
mas meu Deus, existem 8 bolas aqui!
8 8! 1! 8! 1! 8! Mais! Mais! Mais!
O que ocorre aqui é que,
enquanto você tem uma crença
de que aqui existe 10% de chance,
você tem o que eu chamo de um
alief que aqui há 8 bolas,
ao passo que ali, só uma.
Então, alief foi uma noção
discutida com Paul Bloom
na bloggingheads.tv.
E embora estivéssemos filmando
em diferentes lugares,
aqui estou eu na sala de
jogos da minha casa
e aqui está Paul no seu escritório,
parece que fomos
separados no nascimento,
porque estas nossas fotos
foram tiradas no mesmo instante...
Tudo bem.
[risos]
Então vamos supor que
visitamos o Grand Canyon
e eu levo você à passarela de
vidro que está a 1.
200 metros de altura do rio.
E você vai comigo e,
voluntariamente, decide permanecer ali.
Imagino que ao permanecer numa
superfície de vidro
a 1.200 metros acima de um rio furioso,
você acredite que ela é segura.
No entanto, eu aposto que a maioria
de vocês teria calafrios,
tremores e suores.
E isso porque você tem o que eu
chamaria um alief, que diz:
"Eu estou a 1.200 metros de altura,
sem nada me segurando aqui
e eu vou tremer".
Ou imaginem que estamos vendo
um filme de faroeste.
Alguém reconhece este cavalheiro?
Gente, ele era o presidente
quando vocês nasceram.
Quando você assiste a um
filme, um de faroeste,
e as balas ricochetam para
fora do cenário,
obviamente você acredita
que está seguro.
Você não pensa:
"Oh, que bom que as balas não
atravessaram a tela desta vez".
No entanto, no 3D,
você se esquiva do projétil.
Se a gosma verde está saindo pela tela,
você vai ter nojo na poltrona.
Se Anna Karenina está prestes a
morrer, você vai chorar.
Não é porque você acredita
que esteja em perigo,
mas porque você tem um alief.
Quantos de vocês adiantam o
relógio em 5 minutos e,
depois, subtraem de volta?
Quando você faz isso, você
acredita que são 10h10,
mas você tem um alief...
você olha e são 10h05!
Isso entra no seu sistema visual,
é processado muito rápido
e diz 10h05! "Depressa!"
Ou vamos supor que você esteja
assistindo a uma reprise
do seu time de beisebol e você
sabe que se um dos caras
tentar roubar a 2ª base,
ele será eliminado.
E então você grita com a tevê:
"Não corre! Não corre!"
Por quê? Porque você acredita que a
sua voz vai atravessar a tela,
voltar no tempo,
[risos]
ir até a 1ª base e alertar o jogador?
Não.
Você está convicto de
que é uma reprise
e o seu alief diz "não corre".
Imagine agora que você esteja de
dieta, vê este belo pedaço
de bolo de chocolate e tem a crença
de que ele não é desejável.
No entanto, o seu sistema alief, na
forma de cavalo platônico,
vai arrastar você até ele.
[risos]
Vamos supor que seja este o
bolo delicioso...
Isto são rolos Tootsie,
esta é uma fôrma limpa e
esterilizada, aquilo é coco.
De fato, este tem exatamente os
mesmos ingredientes que aquele.
Vocês acreditam em mim, certo?
Eu sou a sua professora, vocês estão
aqui ouvindo o que eu falo.
Acreditem, isto é comestível!
Rolos Tootsie, coco.
[risos]
No entanto, eu presumo que o seu
sistema alief entra em ação.
Vamos supor que eu peça para
você assinar este contrato:
"Venho por este meio
afirmar que a minha alma
pertence somente a ti, ó Satã".
[risos]
E eu escrevo na parte inferior: "Este
não é um contrato legal.
É apenas um experimento de psicologia."
No entanto, você
relutará em assiná-lo.
Não porque você não acredita que
este contrato é legal, certo?
"Oh, meu Deus, se eu outorgar a
minha alma ao diabo...
eu posso garantir que é o
diabo... é pergaminho."
[risos]
Não. Você não acredita que
exista algo para ele,
mas ainda assim você hesita.
Vamos supor que você vá a um
banheiro Monica Bonvicini, que é,
como se vê, completamente
opaco por fora.
Você está fora dele,
olha bem e confirma
que não há nenhuma maneira
de ver o interior.
A sua crença é de que você
está totalmente protegido.
No entanto, quando você vai
usar as instalações,
se parece com isso.
E o seu alief torna
bastante difícil fazer
o que você tinha a intenção de fazer.
Vamos supor que temos 1 saco de
açúcar e 2 copos de água.
E você coloca um pouco de
açúcar num copo
e a etiqueta "Açúcar";
e um pouco de açúcar em outro
com "Veneno".
Você pegou o açúcar,
colocou nos 2 copos
e colou etiquetas neles.
No entanto, as pessoas relutam
em beber deste copo.
Além disso, elas não relutam em
beber apenas quando diz "Veneno".
Elas também relutam em beber quando
está escrito "Sem veneno".
[risos]
Por quê?
Porque a palavra veneno está lá.
Correndo pelo seu sistema alief.
"Bom açúcar.
Mmm, beber açúcar...
Veneno? Veneno? Não beba o veneno!"
Vamos supor que eu tenha uma cozinha
e queira fazer um bolo de
caixa de areia de gato
e as minhas fôrmas de bolo
estão armazenadas aqui.
E um chef chega e diz para mim que
seria muito mais eficiente
se a fôrma estivesse no
armário da direita.
Ele está bastante
satisfeito com o que fez.
E quando eu peço para ele pegar a
fôrma de bolo, ele diz:
"Eu estou tão feliz por mudar as
fôrmas para o armário da direita".
E os dois acreditam que no
armário da direita
é exatamente onde ela deveria estar.
A crença dele é que ela
está no da direita.
O alief dele é um hábito retardado.
Qualquer um de vocês que já
reorganizou o quarto
conhece este sentimento.
Qualquer um de vocês que já
colocou o celular na mão
e então olhou para o celular...
Eu já senti pânico de ter
perdido os meus filhos
e então vi que eles
estavam no meu ombro.
[risos]
Portanto, ter um alief
é, a grosso modo,
ter uma propensão
representacionalmente mediada
para responder a um estímulo
evidente de uma maneira particular.
Certo?
O estímulo aparente da
passarela de vidro,
o estímulo aparente do bolo
de areia para gatos,
você tem uma propensão, seja
inata, como no caso do copo
ou do doce em forma de fezes,
seja habitual, como quando
você organiza a cozinha.
Estas são maneiras habituais
de reagir ao mundo,
ativando o tipo de sistemas
de nível inferior
que comentamos a respeito.
E importante: embora possamos
reconhecer o alief
com mais facilidade olhando para estes
tipos de casos discordantes
– os casos em que a crença
diz para fazer uma coisa
e o alief diz para fazer a outra...
Na verdade, o alief está o
tempo todo ativo.
Toda vez que eu usei o meu polegar
direito para pressionar a tecla,
eu fiz isso pelo alief.
Felizmente,
é algo que corresponde com o
que eu pretendo fazer,
mas isso demonstra que grande
parte de nossas ações
é regida pelo alief.
A questão é: depois de mostrar
que existem centenas de formas
de descrever o que eu expus
como a noção de alief,
por que introduzir este termo novo?
A história tem algo a ver
com o próprio alief.
Portanto, a cada 20 anos ou mais,
o governo dos EUA introduz
uma moeda de dólar.
Aqui está a que eles
introduziram em 1921.
introduziram em 1972.
Aqui está a que eles introduziram
mais tarde, na década de 1980.
Aqui está a que eles introduziram em
1980, com Susan B. Anthony.
Aqui está a da Sacajawea,
introduzida em 2003,
e aqui está a moeda de ouro
de Millard Fillmore,
que será lançada em breve.
O que está acontecendo aqui?
O que está acontecendo é
que é difícil fazer
com que as pessoas usem algo
se isso não se encaixa no sistema
monetário que elas utilizam.
A moeda de dólar não se
encaixa naturalmente
na forma como os
norte-americanos usam o
dinheiro.
Da mesma forma que falar do
sistema 1, do sistema 2,
sistemas relativamente autônomos,
vieses heurísticos e assim por diante
não se encaixam naturalmente
na forma que temos de falar
sobre nós mesmos.
Falamos sobre nós mesmos em
termos de crenças e desejos.
E a fim de fazer uso da moeda de ouro
que é o reconhecimento da
alma multipartida,
precisamos de uma noção que se
encaixa em nossa moeda conceitual.
E esse é o papel que espero
que o alief desempenhe.
O alief vai retornar em
aulas posteriores.
Vamos ouvir falar dele de novo no
contexto da harmonia da alma
e em outros domínios, vamos
ouvir falar de heurística
e vieses e da alma multipartida.
Estou ansiosa para vê-los na
terça-feira, para a harmonia e
felicidade.